und der war eigentlich ziemlich witzig
aber keinen 8
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute spielen wir in jump league eine
abwechselt challenge das heißt sobald
ein modul abgeschlossen wird wechsel ich
mich ab ja erst mal gucken was ich darin
petek widmet die sound sorgt auch ein
bisschen leiser machen
also das war grund ok erstes modul ist
abgeschlossen
dann wechseln wir mal eine spezielle
überraschung für euch hier müssen die
kämmerer controls massensprint es oben
oder unten sprint genau so sehe ich mir
hier immerhin so gerade bei 11.000
berlin
wir haben uns gerade noch macht und
tristar eingezogen ist richtig geil
junge topsprinter hast du gar nichts
niggemann christseins nicken
du bist ein
deswegen habe ich verschicken
kommt deutsch einem 28 uhr ich als sie
achte aus wie der asiate songbook leute
wunderbare job liegt challenge heute ist
es einfach muss man sagen kurz runter da
in dieses handy egal ich hab kein ich
hab dieses modul noch nie gespielt
jetzt hat sich sehr gelungen
hey wer lacht denn da noch im raum
oh mann ich kann mit einer tastatur
nicht spielen
die kassen schaffen das würde mich ja
unter abpacken jeden tag hier so eine
software presse zu haben
ich hab' ich hab nur fenster liegt
fenster licht hatte ich guck mal
wir sind leider nicht auf platz eins ist
die ja genau alter steuerung steuerung
hey ich bin errungen
ich hatte in meinem blog gezeigt die
leute so haye könnte was für ein gaming
kannst du dir mal verlinken und der war
eigentlich ziemlich witzig aber kein 8
ich bin gehört bin teil der kanam er ich
habe auch gemacht
nein ich kenne nicht viele neue modul
ich es ist da wurst
anleger bleiben
meine lieben ja das war ich ändern aber
völlig die steuerung okay mach einfach
also du hast du sprinten abschicken auf
steuerung also der herzen auch wer als
die läufst du letzte springen lässt und
wie geht man nach vorne
usd ach so alles klar dass mein erstes
let's play freunde du musst auch shift
gedrückt hätten
wie oft darf ich verrecke nur ohne dass
ich sterben ist unendlich 00 rechts und
wann wann wechselt ihr euch immer ab was
jetzt das ziel wurden solche leute ist
es normal dass ich so schlecht bin ich
nicht nein aber die wechsels absage mal
ein leben wenn du
als unsichtbar alles klar
ich war direkt ich werde instant aua aua
warum ließt sich auf drei eltern ich
will zuerst sterben so was von klamm
aber ich hab ja warte okay so kurz mal
die angel auf dreieck einfach natürlich
so viel schluchten keine chance leute
ich hatte nur schluchten vor mir
die combo alte jetzt kommt der es in mir
kommt heraus er warte mal ob ich in dem
des menschen sterben werde ich glaube es
nicht
und jetzt wäre die logische und premier
noch lächerliche kompakten der ich lebe
ich liebe diese ja klar aber ich werde
auch garantiert noch mal sterben was man
auch wenn ich hier gespielt habe
darfst du kein tor jetzt gibt mir
nämlich laut braun das wort gibt es
exakt jetzt vermitteln
so nun werden wir haben jetzt was zum
essen passt wenn wir diese runde gewinne
abstauben
das lifestyle ja wir haben als einzige
noch drei leben die anderen ein leben
ohne dass wir haben wir sind paradox
unterstrich 578 erhält im internet
ich hasse solche menschen diese laufen
ich hoffe dann er stirbt eine hunger wie
kinder in afrika
es war nur ein vergleich ja lächerlich
einfach nicht machen versucht dass man
versucht ja ja ich habe zwei leben der
andere 1 1 machen und name herkommt
das heutige video justine und alex der
beschreibung von den teams noch nicht
kennt